tell me about this well we attended the
marquetry class and uh
i did a few pieces this one is what i
dedicated to sherry
what i wanted to start with when we talk
about your story is those beautiful
pictures that we all saw
of you arriving home and being reunited
with your family with sherry and your
two children
how did that moment feel for you
stepping off that plane
back onto british soil and then seeing
your family again
when i think about it now i still found
it difficult to grasp all of that
because
there are many times that i dreamt about
sherry about my kids
and i used to wake up to the ceiling of
my
coffin we used to call because the
ceiling was about about half a meter
above our heads
so
even waking up uh to a ceiling which was
about a few meters away
away from you
it was unbelievable and there were times
that are used to dream and you used to
wake up to that
and it is such an anti-climax then you
wake up
to your cell
sometimes in my dreams i used to test
myself
i used to pinch myself
to feel the pain so that to me to make
sure that this is not a dream so you so
it it's still hard to
finally realize that this is now your
reality
i was touching sherry's hands
touching to make sure that yes this is
this is
reality this is happening
we became serious when she was 17. yeah
we were boyfriends and girlfriends and
we are still boyfriends and girlfriends
so that's a long time without i mean
disregarding whatever we have written
and signed we are that's 50 years she is
my best friend
in life when did you actually believe
that you were coming home what was the
moment that you thought this is actually
happening i'm going home
it was touch and go up until the last
moment
why was that
because the iranian authorities
were
reluctant
although they had they had
told me that i was going to to be
released but you cannot exactly be sure
and
i'm really grateful to stephanie alcac
she did a great job
uh appointed the last moment she made
sure that uh we were she was
accompanying us to the aircraft
and when we took off i mean
she did her job fantastic so so do you
mean you didn't even when you were at
the airport
you were thinking it was only when the
what the wheels
went up yes and you were in the air that
you thought this is even then i was
looking through the window to see if we
are being accompanied by any other
aircraft
and uh when we actually
left the iranian airspace
then i was sure that uh
there was no point of return
going back to august the 13th 2017
when you were arrested tell tell me
about
why you were in iran what you were doing
that day and then what happened
well my mom lives in iran and she's
nearly 90 years old
and she had knee problems and
we arranged and we had the surgery for a
knee replacement
so one day when i was going to the local
market to have my suitcase
repaired this zip didn't
didn't walk properly
as i went down the road
in our street
suddenly a car pulled over
and four men i think it was four
they jumped out and said are you mr
shuri and i said yes
and said one of them took the
suitcase from me and the other one said
can please sit in the back
and
i sat in the back seat
two sat on my sides and the two others
sat in the front and
they started driving and i was wondering
am i being kidnapped or what is it about
so you
so as we got into the motorway one of
them gave me a piece of paper showed it
to me said read it and it was written on
something like anti-espionage
right
[Music]
decreed that it was a court order
that i should be arrested
and
be taken to
a detention center
then
they they they told me to put on a
blindfold
on my on my eyes and then i had to
they told me to
lie on put my head on the laps of the
person who was
sitting next to me
so that i could hear
the traffic
and i could
feel the bumps and everything but you
cannot you you become
disorientated when you're lying on your
side on somebody's lap we mentioned this
into this house i could from
the bottom of my blindfold i could see
very nice carpets
and they took me into a room and i sat
there and my interrogator came and he
used to yeah
and
it started from there
and when i was taken to 209 i was taken
to a room to a cell
and it was left there the cell had
lights strong lights that never went off
there was the sound of this
almost malfunctioning air conditioning
system that
was
continuously going
like that
and
i think a couple of days i was there
without anybody seeing me
and i didn't know what is going on
until my first interrogation i mean were
you thinking this is a misunderstanding
i haven't done anything they don't
believe you
and i didn't know then
the reason why i was there only
long after that we realized when i was
in prison
then when i realized that this is re
this relates to a debt
that uh
britain had to pay to iran
you couldn't speak to anyone nobody came
to me they were just
giving the food through these little
holes
and nobody was talking to me and what
when you say
that they interrogated you what would
what did they do they they sat you in a
room and insisted that you write the
down of things you cannot elaborate on
that okay now okay uh we shall leave
that for later sure
and okay let's talk about evan prison
you wrote something in the guardian that
i read
very carefully
um
you you
it's a prison that housed intellectuals
and political prisoners
and you said in this article i live in
heaven prison
tehran in the valley of hell
is that was is that how it was was it
was it
as if you were living in house israel
that was the value of hell
and because you apart in addition to
your own suffering
you see the suffering of all the people
who are around you
each of them in their in their own
different way
marriages are breaking up
uh families are disintegrating
and
i was reasoning with myself that
if i when i know that i'm innocent and
i'm here
so everybody else can be innocent
and be there
that must be very hard
to live with knowing that the injustice
the injustice of
being imprisoned
for no reason was that hard to was that
hard to live with
especially because if you look at the 68
years of my life
you will not see a single
sign that i was i was having any
political
uh lenience is towards any faction i
mean i was mainly into cosmology i was
in mainly into
engineering uh physics things that i
loved and the innovation that i made in
iran was a certain type of concrete form
work
that i managed to get a gold award for
that the account i read was actually
really hard to read i think it must have
been unimaginable to live it um
you wrote about food so foul that only
the most needy prisoners would eat it
you talked about the unbearable stench
from the open sewers you talked about
the windowless room the bed bugs the
cockroaches yes the rats the feces
floating
[Music]
along this open sewage what was the
worst thing or was that just
impossible to say because it was all
just
so awful they were saying these are
these are the physical things that you
you see
um
but the suffering of the people
who are there
uh a few of them ended up in mental
hospital i mean these are the
the more pronounced
effects
you said um again your testimony about
fellow prisoners you said that you could
name at least half a dozen who'd
attempted suicide at least two who'd
succeeded
have their names with me but i cannot
reveal them but yeah you said there were
a dozen taken to a mental hospital some
had suffered permanent damage due to
electrical shock treatment you said two
dozen had developed severe
post-arrest medical conditions and you
said at least two captives
were killed on their interrogations
or
to have been to have said that they were
there they committed suicide one of them
was kavu zamami
uh the environmentalists
i mean
uh
such fine people such nice people
he should be here with us he he needs
medical attention
and he's not getting it
i mean we cannot celebrate anything
without them being here
i am feeling so much so bitter
that
he was not on the same plane
with us
and i'm not going to be quiet until he
is back
and until the rest of the
dual nationals are released
i feel that i have left
such fine people
you've written about you did attempt yes
that was when i was in the interrogation
center
and uh
i made a few attempts
one of them the scars are on my wrist
when i wanted to cut my wrist
these are the
after four years they are
improving a little bit but
and they barged in and they they
undressed me and they took everything
away
that did that wasn't successful so
i remembered the books that i used to
see for example the people who were
starving in auschwitz
so i thought perhaps if i make a passive
uh hungry strike because you usually
you do a hunger strike to protest
against something
because of the threats which i'm not
going to delve into
so i decided not to be
and
i remember they were giving eggs boiled
eggs for that for breakfast that morning
and i stopped
eating for four days i did not even
drink water
then i thought perhaps my blood would
thicken and if i have a stroke then uh
i'll be handed over to
i didn't want to be so i didn't want to
drink water i didn't want to drink any
to eat anything you lost 17 kilograms in
17 days yes and
that is when my interrogator called me
and he said we are going to show some
kindness and we are going to send you
to a suite and that suite is a cell of
the same size
but with three other people in it
i cried and i insisted because i was
going to i was telling myself that
within the next month
job is accomplished my mission is
accomplished
and i started crying and insisting that
i don't want to be with people i want to
be in the cell of course they had
discovered that i had i was not eating
so they moved me to that cell and the
people in that cell they didn't succeed
in persuading me to eat that evening but
from the next day
uh i stopped my hunger strike there were
some moments
of
hope
companionship
resilience that you've shown in
spades but you you wrote powerfully
about the university of evan
and prisoners given given each other's
lessons
i mean was that something that that
sustained you that helped you this
what tell us about the the university
well you could see uh talented people
around you
this person is a specialist he has got a
phd in quantum physics
the other one has got a phd was a
university professor
up until the moment of his arrest he was
busy lecturing at the university
teaching economics
or
similar cases like that so you would
actually get to know these people
and you would offer
if they could
teach you
a little bit of that
and
to escape from loneliness they would
also welcome that so once i decided
that we should form a group and that
started with a poetry group
and we were about eight or nine we used
to sit together and they used to uh we
had this satirist
writer i cannot name him
and he started teaching us how to write
short stories
and some of them were my role models i
had a friend who had an execution center
sentence over his head
and i was learning a lot from him
somehow we we try to
treat each other
there isn't any other choice
what did you learn from him
resilience
resistance
because every morning when he
woke up say at the middle of the night
he could be called for to be taken to
the gallows
i mean how can you live a life like that
we had we had a few who had execution
sentences
and you don't know what's going to
happen to them now no will you be able
to keep in touch is it very very
difficult
very difficult that must be hard yes
i think the best thing
for us is that
we should concentrate
not on us because we are now safe we are
here
we should concentrate on the people we
have left behind
be it your nationals or mono nationals
and
a lot of effort is needed
that things like this won't happen
many of them are innocent
and their lives are being destroyed just
finally you about have imprisoned you
wrote this i have to stop feeling stop
the feeling of pure rage or self-pity
breakers into choice only survival i'm
not the same person who stepped into the
prison so
i mean this is a
maybe a hard question to answer but how
do you feel now do you feel joyous
do you feel furious are you relieved are
you all of those things
it's a mixture of all of that i cannot
be joyful
because i've got friends back there
who are going through the same suffering
how can i celebrate how can i be be
happy
it's
momentary for example you see
perhaps you see a clip that my son
bought
fish and chips for me for example and
it was so nice
eating fish and chips after nearly five
years or having my first beer
these are
little moments which are quite quite
nice they are quite important but
when you think holy holistically on the
on on the matter you you cannot be
feeling happy
but do you feel guilty i mean you can't
feel guilty that you've been released it
wasn't your fault that you were
imprisoned
you always tell yourself
is it
that thing that i could do or the other
thing that would make the change
so that
another person would be
accompanying me in that aeroplane
again i i stress on the fact that morat
is one of them
[Music]
but there are many others
but i'm not at liberty to to name them
they're there
and the feeling
the the suffering is even more
intensified when you are left behind
we have had people we went to their
send-offs
at the foot of the staircase we used to
clap for them we used to cheer and and
as they were leaving we could feel the
positive atmosphere that we have someone
who is being released from this cage
and we would
congratulate each other as well
and hoping and wishing that i hope your
you will be the next one and the other
moments would say you would be the next
one
but in your heart
you were somehow
feeling that when is it going to be my
time
so when i was walking up those uh
those uh stairs waving at everybody to
say goodbye
i could see that i'm yeah you feel that
you're betraying them you feel that
you don't deserve this
it is them
because they have been so good to you
but you do deserve it
uh
everybody deserves it
and i'm not going to be quiet until i
see all of them back home
and the mono nationals who are there to
be to be released
or to be retried at least
by a fair judge
let's go on to you coming home
and the deal that the government struck
nazanin who you flew home with
said yesterday
that she should have been freed six
years ago it shouldn't have taken five
foreign secretaries to secure her
release
you were held captive for nearly five
years
under four different foreign
secretaries
did you feel
forgotten
i agree with nathan in 100
she in fact put her finger on the right
button and by saying that
she should have been here years ago
if that debt was paid that wasn't a
ransom that was a debt
that the british government owed
should have been paid and if it was paid
perhaps none of this would have happened
so uh
yeah i feel a bit angry
sherry sherry tried to get um
[Music]
an audience with
the prime minister with boris johnson to
talk about your case
her letters were never answered
it took
even a punishment because i i received
my second indictment
because partly because of the voice
message i sent to boris johnson
so i risked my safety
but i managed to
convey that message
to him
unfortunately he did not spend even five
minutes to give a telephone call to my
family
to say that you are there
i see you
tell us about the voicemail what what
thing that i was angry because
uh
i at the same time i was blaming
uh
those who captured us
i was blaming the british government why
don't you do anything about this
do we need a death a dead person in our
hands so that you would start
shaking and moving
and doing something about it
and
i was really angry
and that's why i decided to
send that voice message
hoping that it would make a change
and this was in what 2019 yes i think so
yeah yeah and um
and sherry did not get a response at all
and subsequently and it took it took
richard a hunger strike yes
so you sent boris johnson a voice note
in 2020
to try and get your case
heard by the pm did cherry hear back
from him
nope
unfortunately
she made many attempts
and it was all of them were unsuccessful
and since you've come home
the prime minister's written to you and
sharing would like to see last night we
received a letter
now he is eager to see us
how'd you find how would you interpret
that
well how do you feel about that
i think that uh
it's a bit of oppressionism involved in
it
at the same time as
all of this has happened
under his command
so one could argue that it was the
british government the prison british
government which succeeded in doing that
which is correct at the same time
we could say that why didn't you contact
us my family
and now you are eager
to do that
how would you expect us
to absorb that how would you expect us
to think about our view
with this letter now
what couldn't this letter be sent
five months ago
a year ago
two years ago
why
now and will you will you see him or
you're not deciding i'm not sure okay
just to go back to you and sherry you
studied in the uk
before returning
to iran and you raised your children in
iran but you came back to the uk 17
years ago and you spent so much of your
life here
do you think part of
some of the difficulties with your case
as well was because there was a feeling
that
because you didn't spend your entire
life in the uk that you weren't properly
british was that something that was
underlying this and that must aggrieve
you if it was surely this is one of the
criticisms that i have to make
is that when they were
going to uh my lawyers were applying for
diplomatic protection which nazine got
right yes
uh
our britishness
came under question okay how british are
you
how british should i be
this is the place that we love to be
this is the place we return to
this is the place that we raised our
kids and now both of them have been
educated
uh your university educated people who
are actually serving in this country
how british can should you be
and yes we were not recognized as that
at least practically we were not
make you feel quite angry yes
and particularly for sherry because she
was
here trying to get you that that formal
diplomatic protection that diplomatic
protection status it elevates the case
to becoming a formal state-state issue
so it can make
a real difference can't it yes
which we
did not benefit from it
could you go back to iran
i dare not
that's don't want to go through through
the same ordeal
that's the loss too though isn't it
because your parents
yes my mom is there and i'm worried
about her yeah
i'm sorry for that that's
um extremely worried about her
there was a fundraiser to pay your fine
for your release what happened to that
money and how much did you raise and
what are you going to do with it
first of all i have to
express my gratitude to the british
public
who were so supportive
sherry
had to raise that money overnight
they took everybody the family members
their credit cards whatever they had to
actually to come with that sum
how much did you have to pay
nearly 20 that was 33 000 euros and the
government didn't pay that money for you
and
then they started doing this fundraising
and i'm really grateful
now we have exceeded that
amount and what we intend to do is
to use parts of it for the family to
come
to get on his feet
and the rest we are going to put it in
good use uh perhaps amnesty
international is going to be a
a good candidate that's great well it
must have been hard for sure when you
were
keeping the house
going
uh sacrificed a good portion of her
business yeah uh
campaigning for me
ariane
behind the scene but he was actually
doing the same
okay well look let's talk to let's talk
about your last week i'm coming home
now you've told me about the um
champagne on the plane i heard that you
had a beer in the garden as well
do you have a
beer
what was the first thing you chose to
eat
it was english breakfast british
breakfast
again bacon bacon i love very much and
and sherry has become not a vegetarian
but she doesn't take so she she was
sitting next to me
and i could see that she was taking all
the bits of bacon in her plate and was
transferring it to my place so extra
portions for you well there you go um
and what did you do what did you all do
at the weekend because you had your
children with you and yes yes and in the
safe house that we were we were looked
after yeah first class was that lovely
it was amazing yes and the dogs were the
dogs yeah romeo recognized me
i'm going to ask you one more thing it's
your birthday next month
8th of april yeah how are you going to
celebrate
i'll leave it to sherry and
and the kids
but again it is not going to be a full
celebration
unfortunately until they said the main
celebration is when maura tarbas
returns together with the rest of the
duo nationals
then we are going to raise our
glasses of champagne all together that
will be the that will be my birthday
that will be my no rules
that will be the day
that i imagine
should happen and
i expect for it to happen anymore okay
thank you so much let's talk to you it's
an absolute pleasure same here thank you